welcome to my new news channel we talk
news news and news we're we're bankers
yes somehow I dress like a news anchor
today hey guys come here so everybody
yeah we're playing a game that I've come
up with him a green color shit-faced
it's got alcohol involved so the way
this game works is that we have a list
of five youtubers and we are going to
write who we ship them with wrote and
we're gonna write who we think the other
person ships up with okay and newlywed
game style we're gonna reveal our
answers and try and guess who the other
person ships them with okay so so you
can't change your answer in your head
you've written it down so if I get them
all wrong we'd take consecutive
back-to-back shots yeah first one to
take three shots loses okay yeah yeah
okay the first youtuber is Tyler and
this game is not about who he gets [ __ ]
with the most who you personally ship
them with and who you think I would
personally ship it with this is actually
a lot harder now trying to think in your
head that's a place another good another
danger zone okay next is mamrie Hart I
know that's what I'm trying to figure
out on the next person is Miranda sings
Prince things rankings
oh god who does Miranda [ __ ] Miranda
would know the next person is Sawyer
Hartman who do I thank you shivers okay
and the last persons grace Helbig so who
I should do it and then do I see you
shipping yourself with yes okay fair
enough
oh I feel so dirty after getting in your
mind person oh my god I know you
first person is Tyler right okay now so
who do you think I should be with
another question yeah who do i who i
think you ship Tyler with okay is your
show who I should know I'm gonna show my
answer will you show me yours close out
like as you mentioned that earlier they
didn't already keep my mouth shut
ya know who do you think I ship Tyler
with choice of awed Radisson okay next
person is mamrie Hart I'll go with this
one first
wait so it's who do you think I ship her
with yeah okay go ahead
ready whatever you are but it's who I
ship her with yeah okay so you should
here's who I think you should pray with
this I have no [ __ ] clue
I put Kingsley I put max y'all should
just try it
all right now smell em up who do you
think I ship memory with Tyler Flula oh
yeah she's a German it's
man chuckles okay next is we're into
sing where the sings so this is who I
think you ship for with and again I had
no idea so I just want Tyler
I think Connor Franta never hold hands I
don't think Brandon becomes to be
embarrassing I love it
okay now who do I think you should her
with Miranda yeah come on Joey Graceffa
shipped her with herself
Miranda sings so creepy
oh that's right question that's my OTP
Miranda and Miranda I got one right on
this so far let's say you're at two and
I don't want your oh okay now it's on to
Sawyer now who I think you ship yourself
with Tyler okay now who do I show you I
think you should meet with Tyler last
one is grace Helbig and who I think you
ship you with I I could have very easily
said but I said this Hannah I said
Chester see oh really I wanted to see
that oh yeah bottles drink throughout Oh
you drink awesome a couple of big
misleading for a purpose so now we're
both it too hard it to it out
a good time I think this is the only one
I got right unless you jumped ship since
when I am here we go
who do I think you ship yourself with
both the gangbang Jack and Finn is that
right Wow Sawyer takes his shot of loss
and regret and pain and agony that
you're sharing with yeah thanks for
watching guys tomorrow
sorry about the video app where we floor
review today I'm not really sure but
just go over to his channel and keep
refreshing until a new video comes out
it's a charity challenges for church
challenges for charity where we drank
because clearly that's how you support
to reduce oh just go check out this
channel the link served all over the
place that's it I don't know